figaro live bonjour nous sommes en
direct ce mardi matin pour faire un
nouveau point sur la situation en
ukraine puisque aujourd'hui cela fait
trois mois que le conflit a débuté et
pour en parler aujourd'hui je suis avec
patrick st paul rédacteur en chef du
service principal du figaro bonjour
patrick bonjour à ça on va décrypter
grâce aux cartes réalisées par le
service infographie tout ce qui s'est
passé dans ce conflit et toutes les
dernières évolutions effectivement et
vous n'hésitez pas bien évidemment à
poser vos questions dans les
commentaires et on essaiera d'y répondre
au mieux comme d'habitude patrick la
première question que j'avais c'est
trois mois après le début de la guerre
quelle est la situation générale on peut
dire la situation génère il ya eu
plusieurs phases dans cette guerre en
fait ya eu deux guerres dans en une
seule guerre la guerre d'abord est clair
que tentait de mener vladimir poutine
qui pensaient conquérir le pays en dans
une guerre éclair de 72 heures qui
devait décapité le régime à kiev donc
l'objectif était de prendre kiev est de
faire tomber à la fois la présidence le
gouvernement et toutes les institutions
ukrainienne cette première bataille a
échoué c'était le premier mois de guerre
en réalité les forces l'ukrainienne ont
réussi à repousser les forces russes
qui étaient au nord-est et au nord ouest
de kiev y avait deux fronts en fait pour
tenter de prendre le contrôle de kiev
notamment par des opérations commandos
dans un premier temps et ensuite par des
plusieurs tentatives de pousser vers le
centre ville de kiev en fait lire les
forces russes ont été fixés
sur un front à ma km et sur l'autre à
environ 35 km et ensuite les forces
ukrainiennes ont repoussé les russes et
jusque jusqu'à la frontière avec la
biélorussie on it et elles ont forcé un
retrait russie ensuite on est entré au
bout d'un mois environ un mois et demi
dans la seconde phase puisque une phase
aussi où les forces russes qui étaient
déployés vers kiev se sont redéployés
vers le nom basse et ensuite a commencé
la guerre pour le nom basse avec des
objectifs
russ révisé à la baisse c'est à dire de
faire le fameux corridor qui permet de
relier le dombass à la crimée en passant
par l'est et le sud est du pays et donc
là on assiste depuis un mois et demi à
la guerre dans le donbass avec
pas mal d'avancé russes qui ont les deux
la grande victoire et qui s'est conclu
ce dimanche par la reddition des
dernières forces retranché à marioupol
dans les usines azoff talent en fait
voilà c'est la grande victoire de pour
l'instant de vladimir poutine qu'il peut
afficher c'est la conquête de marioupol
mais marioupol en ruine est complètement
détruite qui fait penser
à la tchétchénie à alep en syrie c'est à
dire une ville voilà en ruine vidée
d'une grande partie de sa population
il a conquis une seconde ville dans le
donbass qui est personnes donc ça mario
pas les personnes sont les deux
principales villes qui là qu'il a
conquis et on voit qu'il est pas mal
d'avancé quand même sûr si on regarde la
carte le front était avant
ahizoune où on entend les forces russes
tenter d'avancer vers ce l'audience et
clament à tort sq voilà toute cette zone
qui est en fait le nord de l'oblast de
de
lougansk a été conquis par les forces
russes et
et elles descendent aussi vers vers le
sud donc on voit cette fameuse fameux
mouvement en tenailles où l'objectif des
forces russes et de prendre en tenaille
tout ce qui au milieu entre les deux
zones rouges en fait c'est à dire de nip
aux apories djia et de contrôler toute
cette zone
du pays tout l'est du pays donc les 2
the blast qui constitue
la région du donbass
et on note aussi
des avancées des forces l'ukrainienne
puisque au nord dans la région de car
qui veulent les russes n'ont jamais
réussi à accomplir est quartier en
revanche la ville a été son bison que
c'est la deuxième ville du pays qui a
été soumise à d'intenses bombardements
les russes étaient dans l'est dans les
faubourgs de karkhiv et là il ya une
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui
qui a relativement porté ses fruits
puisque les forces russes se sont
retirés de la région de kharkiv sous la
pression de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne et maintenant on fait quoi
on assiste c'est une
c'est une contre offensive ou en fait
les forces ukrainienne tente de prendre
un revers cette fameuse thonaille russe
par le nord et de redescendre pour pour
reconquérir ces zones et ce qui change
la donne aujourd'hui c'est que dans les
armes qui sont donnés par les
occidentaux aux ukrainiens on a des
armes des canons de longue portée dont
qui permettent de frapper
entre 30 et 55
km
donc on a les fameux canons witcher 2
livrés par les états unis on a les
canons caesar qui commence à entrer en
action donc son tir et commencer à tirer
avec c'est avec ces deux matériels qui
change un peu la donne parce que ça
permet de modeler le terrain en
profondeur d'aller frapper des forces
russes derrière
les premières lignes et notamment
ça empêche les russes de faire venir
toute leur logistique tout leur
approvisionnement en munitions et ils
sont obligés
de les mettre à une distance plus grande
et donc l'approvisionnement du du front
de toutes les munitions de tout ce qui
permet d'avancer plus rapidement sur le
terrain est ralentie par ces armements
qui ont été livrées aux ukrainiens voilà
à peu vous me donnez aujourd'hui très
bien merci pour ce portrait des prises à
l on va rentrer un peu plus dans les
détails est ce qu'on peut dire à presser
pour la vue c'est cette première phase
sarsar quand même ressembler vraiment
une défaite pour vladimir poutine par
rapport à son objectif initial par
rapport aux objectifs premiers c'était
évidemment une défaite puisque il avait
trois objectifs principaux
l'un était de 2,2 des nazis fier ils
appellent ça des nazis fier le type ce
que considère que les pro occidentaux
sont en fait deux c'est une forme de
nazisme pour lui visiblement et il fait
référence à un tas de choses historique
de dans le dans le passé de l'ukraine
notamment pendant la la seconde guerre
mondiale
donc c'était 2d nazifié le pays en le
décapitant
de démilitariser
l'ukraine est de placer un gouvernement
fantoche pro russe à la tête de
l'ukraine tout cela en 72 heures on a vu
que dans
certains nombre de véhicules dont des
chars les uniforme de parade était
étaient placés dans les véhicules non
qu'ils aient dit clairement les forces
russes se sont dit on va arriver en 72
heures on va défiler dans kiev est en
fait la grande parade de la victoire de
la seconde guerre mondiale qui a eu lieu
le 9 mai c'est lui mais pour nous avec
le calendrier enfin avec le décalage
horaire c'était ça tombait à 9 mai en
russie et donc cette grande parade
devait avoir lieu à kiev et ça ça n'a
pas eu lieu et donc c'est une des c'est
une défaite pour vladimir poutine assez
clair
maintenant il n'a pas bien qu'il se soit
reconcentrer dans un premier temps sur
l'objectif du dombass qui est un
objectif qui est plus accessible avec
une stratégie qui est maintenant une
stratégie de guerre longue d'enterrement
de de la guerre sont des choses les
guerres larvées de vladimir poutine et
l'armée russe maîtrise mieux qu'une
guerre éclair ou là ça demande des
méthodes modernes qui sont plus calquée
sur les méthodes de l'otan et avec la
structure de commandement russe en fait
c'est très difficile parce que les
officiers de terrain non pas les
initiatives et ce sont les généraux qui
sont sur le terrain et c'est une forme
de commandement qui est extrêmement
rigide et peu adapté aux conflits
modernes et cela veut dire que
voilà dès qu'un général et tuer les
ordres d circulent plus or il ya 11
généraux qui ont été tués tués grâce
notamment aux renseignements américains
donc ça a beaucoup compliqué les choses
pour vladimir poutine maintenant il est
dans le donbass avec un objectif plus
accessible avec une guerre qui va durer
qui va éprouver le soutien des
occidentaux est ce qu'on va quand même
continuer à livrer des armes
à la même fréquence
à l'ukraine ce sera compliqué d'abord
d'un point de vue logistique parce qu'il
faut produire ces armes et qu'on a vu
que la chaîne d'approvisionnement
commençait à s'essouffler un peu c'est
extrêmement compliqué et puis par
ailleurs il y à la détermination qui
peut avec le temps ces mousses et
notamment avec la pression sur les
opinions publiques qui vont être aussi
éprouvé dans leur pouvoir d'achat par
cette guerre alors on a dans les
commentaires pro kadiri qui nous
remercient pour toutes ces informations
je profite pour le saluer n'hésitez pas
à poser vos questions gilles qui nous
dit la guerre piétine on en a parlé de
cette guerre très rapide au début on est
sur une guerre qui pourrait durer des
mois voire des années finalement bien
sûr le conflit dure déjà depuis 2014
c'est une guerre dans le donbass
où les gens sont bien rodés à cette
guerre qui est qui était décrite comme
un conflit larvé mais un conflit larvé
où tous les jours il y avait des
bombardements à l'artillerie des combats
à l'armé légère et malgré le cessez le
feu qui était censé être en vigueur ce
cessez feu étaient des constamment
violés d'ailleurs y avait des
observateurs occidentaux qui qui étaient
là et qui était observé les choses et
qui notait toutes les violations de
cessez le feu qui se produisaient tous
les jours donc voila depuis 2014 on peut
de
ce conflit peut encore durer pendant
pendant pendant des mois des années 10
ans
15 ans et c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas du tout exclu en fait justement on
appareil de la taille et qui était à
l'est du pays parce qu'il faut rappeler
que il y a une ligne de front qui l'a
depuis 2014 et que les russes n'ont pas
pu progresser de façon aussi rapide
entre guillemets qu'ils l'ont fait dans
le sud par exemple
depuis 2014 les forces russes n'était
pas impliqué directement dans les
combats s'étaient les séparatistes qui
se battaient qui était soutenu et armé
par par la russie
et qui elle en fait étaient dans des
positions
avec des tranchées ça ressemble un peu
la guerre à la guerre 14-18 de ce point
de vue là à dire que c'est vraiment une
guerre de tranchées avec des
bombardements et ce qui s'est passé
alors il ya à la fois les avancées des
forces russes puisque maintenant les
forces russes sont directement impliqués
dans les combats avec beaucoup plus
d'hommes beaucoup plus de matériel
beaucoup plus de moyens aussi des moyens
aériens des appuis a rien qui permette
de soutenir les offensives au sol il ya
aussi autre chose c'est que par choix
les ukrainiens dans certains endroits on
choisit de d'opérer des retraits
stratégique des positions qui était
devenu indéfendable ils ont préféré se
retirer pour économiser leurs troupes et
en construisant d'autres positions
défensives
donc là ils sont retranchés ce qu'on
voit actuellement sur la carte sur des
positions où ils se sont enterrés aussi
et ça risque d'être dans la seconde
phase de cette guerre du nom basse
ça reese les avancés risquent d'être
beaucoup plus lente et ça ça va
s'enliser davantage puisque voilà ces
lignes sont enterrés et c'est des forces
défense des positions défensives ça les
ukrainiens safer et ils sont ils sont
ils sont installés dans ces positions
qui vont être difficiles à déloger on
l'a vu à marioupol qui est qui qui est
tombé d'ailleurs j'ai eu notre
infographie fait partie graphique qui
est ici attendez je vais vous la place
c'est pour qu'on voie un peu ce qui
s'est passé l'évolution la bataille de
marioupol qui a débuté assez tôt dans le
conflit qui dirait un adjectif prêt dès
les premiers jours du conflit qui était
un objectif principal pour
vladimir poutine et qui a finalement mis
près de trois mois pour couvrir cette
ville oui alors oui c'était un objectif
dès le début pour lanières poutine
puisque ça ça le port de marioupol donne
accès
et non seulement l'accès mais le
contrôle à la mer d'azov
en fait c'est que si en contrôlant à la
fois l'île aux serpents et mario paul ça
permet de
contrôler tous les mouvements dans la
mer d'azov
ce qui évidemment pour
l'objectif est à la fois militaire et
aussi économique puisque ça permet
d'asphyxier totalement l'économie
du tri yann qui les crânes ne peut plus
exporter de blé ne peut plus exporter un
tas de choses qui étaient produites
notamment de produits agricoles
et la guerre a duré
trois mois
d'abord
il ya eu des combats intenses partout
dans mario paul et donc ça s'est soldé
par des par des bombardements très très
lourd qui ont détruit la ville à 90 %
c'est selon les estimations c'est 90%
des bâtiments
publics et d'habitations ont été
détruits en ville une grande partie de
la population a fui la ville et le
dernier mois de combat
s'est concentrée dans l'usiné d'âge of
talent qui est un complexe de production
d'acier qui s'étend sur 14 km avec des
kilomètres aussi de galeries
souterraines où étaient retranchés
plusieurs brigades de
l'armée ukrainienne d'une part la 29e ma
garde de l'armée ukrainienne qui est une
force qui a une grande expérience du
combat et par ailleurs
la brigade parce que c'est maintenant
une
une noyade du régiment azoff kaki et le
sulfureux régiment puisqu'il ya un
certain nombre à sa création
de
deux personnalités appartenant à des
mouvements néo-nazis qui ont fondé ce
mouvement qui ensuite à agréger un tas
d'autres combattants parce que son grand
fait d'armes est d'avoir dans la guerre
de 2014
reconquis la ville de marioupol qui
avait été déjà conquise une première
fois par les forces séparatistes et à ce
moment là les le régiment azoff avaient
réussi à repousser ses forces et grâce à
ce fait de gloire
le régiment a attiré un tas de
volontaires qui ceux qui ont été
recrutés
dans ce
régiment est par ailleurs il a été
reconnu officiellement
comme une brigade rattaché au ministère
à la défense territoriale donc non pas
au ministère de la défense ministère de
l'intérieur ukrainien et
donc c'est ces combattants
dont le nombre exact qui étaient
retranchés à l'intérieur du
de ce complexe et difficile à évaluer
entre entre deux et trois mille
combattants
ont combattu de façon héroïque pendant
pendant des mois dans ce
et notamment pendant le dernier mois a
retranché dans ce complexe et
et ça a permis de fixer en réalité un
certain nombre de forces russes à
marioupol et
empêchant le redéploiement des forces
russes sur d'autres fronts à l'intérieur
du nom basse donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont considérés comme eric il savait la
bataille de marioupol perdu depuis le
départ mais ils ont continué de se
battre pour
atteindre un espèce de but stratégique
qui était de forcer les les
pires russe à ralentir lors leur
offensive dans le reste du nombre et du
coût maintenant que marioupol est tombé
ces forces russes vont pouvoir se se
redéployer dans les ailes sont en grande
partie déjà redéployées parce que la
même si le dénouement à et lieu dimanche
ça faisait un moment qui avait plus que
quelques centaines de combattants
retranché dans une usine donc les les
forces russes ont déjà été redéployés
redistribuer sur les autres fronts du
noma la question est maintenant de
savoir combien de temps le
dombass va tenir face à face à l'armée
face à la messe qui on l'a dit avance
petit à petit dans cette région
oui alors comme comme je l'expliquais
justement c'est maintenant que les
ukrainiens sont
retranché dans des possibles position
défensive avec avec plusieurs lignes de
trancher plusieurs lignes défensives
visiblement
des choses extrêmement solides qui ont
été construites
l'avancée des forces russes va devenir
plus compliqué parce que il ya eu un
certain nombre de repli stratégique de
l'armée ukrainienne sur des positions
qui étaient devenus
deux positions perdant qui était devenu
difficilement défendable et maintenant
ils seront tranchées dans des positions
qui sont beaucoup plus compliqué à
prendre donc jeu
et avec comme je disais tout à l'heure
l'armement que qui étaient fournis
france d'ukraine yann je pense ça va
devenir plus compliqué pour les russes
d'avancer rapidement et c'est une guerre
qui risque de devenir redevenir une
guerre de position
avec des progressions très lente
est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui ce que
cherche vladimir poutine s'était on le
savait au début du conflit est ce qu on
sait qu il peut s'il va s'arrêter aux
dons bas si ensuite il peut continuer en
portant justement sur une guerre plus
longue est-ce qu'on a une idée de ça
alors on a une idée il ya d'abord ce que
dit vladimir poutine lui-même et il faut
jamais oublier que d'écouter vladimir
poutine parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui en général
dit ce qu'il fait
fait ce qu'il dit
donc lui pour l'instant son nouvel
objectif et comme il l'a annoncé de
conquérir la totalité du dombass
pour le rattacher à la russie
il y a eu notamment dans l'oblast de
lougansk on a introduit le rouble donc
et une double monnaie mais l'objectif à
terme est de retirer la rive nahla la
monnaie ukrainienne donc on voit qu'en
russie fille ces zones que toute
l'administration tout tout la façon de
gérer jusqu'à la monnaie est contrôlé
par les russes en vue d'un rattachement
l'objectif affiché est donc de
reconquérir tous le dombass
et de prolonger sur au sud jusque
jusqu'à là au dessin et
donc de contrôler tout le sud ce qui
permet de faire la jonction avec la
transnistrie qui est une autre zone
séparatiste
qui a vu l'allemand russe et qui voit là
ça permet d'avoir une continuité
territoriale jusqu'à la crimée et
jusqu'à la moldavie
donc ça c'est l'objectif affiché par
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui mais
d'après ce que disent des services de
renseignement américains
le kremlin n'a pas du tout renoncé à ses
objectifs premiers il ajuste réagencer
ses objectifs une fois qu'il aura
conquis le nom basse et réaliser tous
ces objectifs premiers dans le sud
l'objectif principal reste de conquérir
en réalité la totalité de l'ukraine et
ensuite de
faire pour y arriver plus tôt de re
lancer une offensive sur kiev de
décapiter le
régime et ensuite de prendre tout
contrôle du pays très bien ça reste
d'après les américains son objectif
c'est difficile à vérifier puisque ce
sont des des renseignements fournis par
les parts par les services de
renseignement américains qui eux aussi
ont ils y à une guerre de l'information
ils sont dans ces guerres dans
l'information dans la même portion de
carrus donc c'est moi c'est ce qu'ils
disent mais c'est difficile de savoir si
c'est une réalité
ou non il faut effectivement faire très
attention l'avait dit en temps de guerre
effectivement sur ses chances des points
là il ya aussi la question du du
contrôle des villes dès qu'ils se posent
on va justement de remplacer la monnaie
par exemple la ville de carson qui est
une grande ville qui est sous contrôle
russe depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
c'est un enjeu aussi pour les russes
d'arriver à finalement avoir la
population de ces villes et de les
garder sans rob et lyon ouais on voit
qu'à carson 7 depuis le début c'est très
compliqué on se souvient de ces images
ou en fait la population de personnes et
celles qui étaient montés sur sur les
chars russes armés de drapeaux ukrainien
pour eux c'était des images très fortes
et qui étaient en fait les premières
images qui permettait de de contrer la
propagande du kremlin selon laquelle en
fait voilà ces populations russophones
puisque personne est une ville
majoritairement russophone en fait et
son pro russe et rêvait de leur
rattachement à la russie et on vous
voyez qu'en réalité tout est poli
populations sont extrêmement attachés à
leur identité au drapeau ukrainien et
qu'elles ont montré aux forces russes
qui sont entrées en ville que qu'elles
ne sont pas les bienvenues qu'elles ne
serait pas accueilli avec du pain et du
sel comme comme cela avait été prétendu
par les officiers qui qui poussait au
combat
les soldats russes et qu'en réalité
les ukrainiens veulent leur indépendance
et rejette toute forme d'annexion par la
russie cela signifie que la seule façon
pour la russie de contrôler ces villes
c'est en instaurant un régime
extrêmement dur donc on est dans un
système dictatorial
à la russe mais mais beaucoup plus
autoritaire avec un contrôle beaucoup
plus étroit de la population avec une
répression très forte de toute forme de
concept de contestation
c'est quelque chose qui n'aide pas
beaucoup
les forces russes parce que évidemment
quand on voit
tous tout ça circule sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya des images des gens qui
témoignent et donc dans les autres
villes d'ukraine où les combats ont lieu
la population voit ce qui se passe dans
ses villes et entre le modèle ukrainien
de vie un peu l'occidentale et le modèle
autoritaire russe qui appliquée de façon
extrêmement rigoureuse dans ces villes
conquises par par les russes les
ukrainiens ont vite fait leur choix en
réalité est ce que on avait une question
sur cela sur les sur les possibles
négociations entre apple ya eu des
négociations assez rapidement au bout de
quelques semaines depuis un don plus
parler il ya plus personne à la table
des négociations aujourd'hui alors on en
a entendu parler récemment puisque
à la volée demi de volodymyr the north
qui eux
a expliqué qu'il y aura une pause dans
les négociations
il ne parle pas de rupture mais de pause
en raison d'une impossibilité de
dialogue avec les russes selon lui
puisque les russes restent sur une
position qui est très dure et qui n'a
pas varié depuis le début du conflit en
dépit de l'évolution de la situation sur
le terrain et qui est en réalité une
reddition totale des ukrainiens avec une
soumission à la volonté russe c'est à
dire de contrôle total du pays avec un
changement de régime est un pays qui qui
qui deviendrait en fait ce que ce que
les russes appelle la neutralité c'est
en fait une soumission à la russie est
un pays qui est démilitarisé donc c'est
une solution qui est évidemment
inacceptable pour les ukrainiens
d'autant plus qu'ils ont l'impression à
juste raison souvent d'avoir engrangé un
certain nombre de victoires militaires
il croit même s'ils savent que ce sera
un effort de longue haleine que la
victoire est possible
les ukrainiens ne se bat pas dans une
guerre
est une guerre de conquête c'est une
guerre pour défendre leur pays pour
défendre la survie de leur pays la
survie de leur nation et c'est devenu
pour eux une sorte de guerre
d'indépendance
en réalité puisque ils ont voté très
massivement en 1991 pour la séparation
avec la russie
cette séparation n'a pas eu lieu dans
les faits elle a eu lieu puisque
l'ukraine est devenue un pays
indépendant 91 mais en réalité elle
restait très très imbriqué très lié à la
russie et ensuite c'est avec le site une
série de révolutions une première en
2004 une seconde en 2014 évolution de
maidan que peu à peu ce sentiment
d'émancipation vis-à-vis des russes qui
se faisait de plus en plus étouffant est
devenu plus fort et aujourd'hui ils sont
dans une guerre d'indépendance donc les
conditions qui sont dictées par leur ai
dit mir poutine sont absolument
inacceptables pour les ukrainiens et
voleuse mirena ce qui a signifié à
vladimir poutine qu'il devait tenir
compte à la fois de la situation
internationale c'est à dire très grande
pression et du très grand d'isolement
dont il est l'objet dans le monde et de
la situation sur le terrain où les
forces
l'ukrainienne ont engrangé des victoires
donc voila et
les forces us craignent anfa la partie
ukrainienne elle
son objectif clairement et de récupérer
la totalité du dombass y compris les
zones conquises par les séparatistes
depuis 2014 ils disent officiellement
que la crimée
est aussi une zone qu'ils voudraient
dont il voudrait reprendre le contrôle
on voit mal comment ça pourrait se
produire le rattachement de la crimée à
la russie a été votée par référendum
même si s'est tenue dans des conditions
qui ont évidemment peu transparentes et
démocratiques
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui ils sont
très compliqué de revenir en arrière là
dessus mais les ukrainiens crois
fermement que par
un effort de longue haleine ils peuvent
reconquérir la totalité du nom bath et
donc ils sont prêts à négocier un statut
particulier pour le don base dans les
négociations et avoir une phase
transitoire mais ils sont plus du tout
prêt à
accéder à toutes les demandes des russes
nous qu'on est en fait dans un direct de
sourds et seule l'évolution de la
situation militaire sur le terrain ainsi
qu'éventuellement
l'attitude de la communauté
internationale peut avoir une provoquer
une inflexion dans les positions des uns
et des autres qui permettrait une
possibilité de dialogue parce
qu'aujourd'hui en réalité il n'y a pas
de possibilité de dialogue et c'est là
qu'on voit aussi qu'à la maison blanche
il ya certains conseillers de joe biden
est aussi dans la presse libérale
notamment via un éditorial du new york
times le week-end dernier où dans lequel
il était dit
qu'il faut montrer à volodimir zenasci
quelles sont les limites du soutien
occidental que ce n'est pas un soutien
à tout prix et que les états unis ne
doivent pas se laisser entraîner dans
une guerre de participer directement à
une guerre contre la russie et que donc
pour ça il faut montrer clairement
quelles sont les lignes à volodimir
zenasci ça c'est une chose aussi
qui évolue constamment ce soutien
occidental qui a une influence sur
l'attitude des ukrainiens dans les
négociations et donc on va voir comment
tout toutes ses positions en fait vont
évoluer dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent et si une fenêtre de
dialogue va s'ouvrir et sera possible
entre les russes et les ukrainiens très
bien merci beaucoup patrick d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui pour paris la
situation en ukraine vous rappelle que
ça fait trois mois aujourd'hui que le
conflit a démarré je vous remercie en
tout cas d'avoir été très nombreux à
nous suivre à poser vos questions merci
aussi au service infographie du figaro
qui nous a fourni ses cartes vous pouvez
retrouver dans le journal du jour bien
évidemment et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives dans fear alive